Let's examine the
velocities of objects
in the center of
mass reference frame.
So we have object
1 and object 2.
And we have CM.
And we have r1 prime.
And we have r2 prime.
And recall that we found that
the position vector, r1 prime,
was equal to the
reduced mass over mu
m1 times the relative
position to r1, 2.
I'll draw that up here,
r1, 2 from 2 to 1.
And just to remind
you, r1 minus r2.
And likewise the
position vector r2 prime
is minus mu m2 over r1, 2.
Well, now we can
differentiate the positions
in the center of mass frame.
And we find that
the V1, which is,
of course, the derivative
of the position,
is just mu over m1 V1, 2.
And V2 prime is equal to mu
over m2 with a minus sign V1, 2.
Now the significance
of this result
is that the velocity
of the object
in the center of mass frame is
equal to some constant times
the relative velocity.
Likewise, velocity V2 prime
in the center of mass frame
is also proportional
to a constant.
And it's in minus the
relative velocities.
So the significance
of this result
is that when we looked at
an elastic one-dimensional
collision, we already
have the result
that the relative
velocities, V1, 2 initial,
is minus the final
relative velocity.
And we also know
from what we saw
that the relative velocity is
independent of the reference
frame.
So this condition
about relative velocity
is true in any reference frame.
And in particular, it's true
in the center of mass frame.
So what that shows us is
that these conditions,
this statement, is
that the magnitude
of the relative
velocity is constant.
And the conclusion is because
in the center of mass frame,
V1 prime is proportional
to the relative velocity.
That tells us that in a
center of mass reference frame
that the initial
velocity of object
1 in the center of mass frame
is equal to the final velocity
of object 1.
So the quantity, the speed
of objects 1 and objects 2
in an elastic collision in the
center of mass reference frame
do not change magnitude.
We can call this
quantity V2 prime
and likewise V
prime 2 initial is
equal to V2 final
prime V2 prime.
And this will make our
analysis of collisions
in the center of mass
reference frame very easy.
Two objects, when
they're colliding
in the center of
mass reference frame,
their speeds do not change.
Only the direction of
their velocities change.